if you don't really think these things
through all the way hegel's saying
you're just playing around with empty
signifiers it's fun to do you can hang
out with all your you know friends
whether online or in hegel groups or
something like that and chitter chatter
about this sort of thing
but you're not really getting
what he's saying and you know this is a
bit of a
let's call this a rant on my part right
a lot of people read the phenomenology
and they you know they read the preface
they usually skip over the introduction
because the preface is so much cooler
and they you know get through the the
consciousness section and they're mostly
interested in you know uh the very first
part of it and the very end part of it
right so they're interested in the sense
perception right and and uh the
consciousness of that
um and then they're interested in the
you know force and the understanding and
they don't spend the time to actually
understand then they want to get to the
the really cool stuff the master slave
dialectic which means reading the you
know the first part the truth of
self-certainty and then they kind of you
know skim through the stoicism
skepticism unhappy consciousness even
though that's bigger and then they get
to the you know the reason section and
the spirit section which are the biggest
parts of the book right that's the bulk
of the phenomenology
and they you know they touch here and
there on things well you know we should
talk about the beautiful soul in the
spirit section and we definitely should
talk about the phrenology and
physiognomy section because it's got
that cool quote spirit as a bone which
hegel is saying spirit is not a bone you
should punch people out who actually
think that but they miss all that and
then they get to this this section and
they're talking about spirit and hegel
would say you you don't know
what you're talking about because you
haven't done the
rigorous work of getting through all of
this stuff all right rant over
caution over
uh let's let's jump into the what he
says here so